anyway the next category actually hit it
what is it best complaining about
america moments you mean the entire
broadcast
well well when did this start to become
a thing i got
i don't know i think i started casually
complaining about america and we all
joined yeah what was the first
complaining about america i remember
what started this and then just like
there's so many differences
i i feel like this wasn't a thing at the
beginning of the podcast and then
something happened and then like the
floodgates just opened yeah
right like i can't remember i think it's
when our audience kind of caught on
being like these guys
love to complain about america for some
reason my jacket off for this one
i'm getting hot this is heated
this is a heated topic my favorite one
let's look at the nominees let's look at
the nominations
wearing
they put like a cloth on the bed like a
little like i don't know like that [ __ ]
apparently it's so that you can wear
shoes on the bed
oh yeah oh i still feel that way you
know yeah i'm pretty sure that's what it
is ever since i found that out i just i
hate that thing now no i didn't mind it
i thought it looked nice but no legit
every ever ever since i found out about
that the first thing i do when i get to
a hotel
rip that [ __ ] off put in the corner
pretty sure it just breaks the [ __ ]
geneva convention right
like like how is this allowed like some
really important issues going on in the
world
and this should be up there like number
one this needs to be sorted out the
other one is american pint versus
british point play
it's true american pine's the biggest
scam ever by the way you guys got ripped
off well i don't know why
when americans took the pint from us for
some reason they made it smaller
this is true yeah why would they do this
and then everything else
bigger yeah the only thing that matters
the only thing that matters
a pint a point how do you [ __ ] that up
how do you [ __ ] that up america
the only thing where you actually care
about your cost to quantity ratio yeah
is when they're like oh hold on a second
hold on let's make it smaller let's not
get too big
it's like no no especially when we're
talking about american beers as well you
don't need
less american beers to get you drunk you
need more of it more of it
uh what's this third one america is
dangerous
yeah that's just a general statement is
that just a statement
i've never been to a motel so i don't
[ __ ] with those yeah because
that's why people die in films that's
why fugitives like hide out
right every single thing that's bad
happens near a motel oh man i don't even
remember that episode i don't remember
that episode but i guess we're talking
about how dangerous
american motel is yeah america is
dangerous i mean i've never stayed in
a motel before but i can just already
tell i mean everybody
i want to simulate near death um so i do
want to say
i want to simulate my favorite quentin
tarantino movie at a motel
i want to see if there's somebody like
changing identities in the room next
year yeah yeah and
and blowing up that i've actually stayed
in a motel before really yeah i felt
sketch as [ __ ] yeah right
because i i remember like like the first
time i take stay the motel was like
before ax
and i remember getting to the parking
lot and i'm just like there's at least
like been five people you've been shot
here
i feel like oh my god
i feel like with someone doing [ __ ]
heroin around the corner or something
it felt sketchy to be fair you could say
that about any street corner in l.a
i'm sorry it was my first time i like
you america yeah come on i love you too
but come on now uh american food is
disgusting
which is where like the optimal place of
where you do that and i just saw like
six americans dipping their fries
into their shakes i'm just like i can't
i can't be here yeah no i couldn't
it literally ruined my steak and shake
experience my official reaction there is
interesting because i'm not really that
against it right
i i don't i don't hate it i've done it
before i thought it was okay i
understand
the flavors why you'd want to do that
[Laughter]
yeah i mean this one i mean the thing
about american food is that i don't
actually think american food is
disgusting
do you throw one or a ten yeah yeah one
or two yeah yeah they either absolutely
nail it and they have the best food on
earth
yeah or they have like white castle yeah
yeah the five guys are white castle
yeah top or the bottom it's it's like
you you either you
either way you destroy your body but is
it like is it does it feel good or does
it feel bad
yeah yeah it's it's it's like the you
know the
uh what was the show that did like the
crazy hot scale
oh yeah yeah uh was it like that's the
show [ __ ] include
that i i forgot the name of the show i
know what you're talking about
i had an analogy there then i completely
lost it uh and then the last one is
americans are a different species of
human
strength what is this clip
i love americans but there's just like
just general life stuff there's like
what what
every time i go to america i'm like this
is another planet like i i can't relate
to these
well that's obviously a bit of an over
exaggeration i cannot relate to a lot of
americans
there's just some things where i'm just
like all right i can't believe this is a
thing
i can't i can't remember what we
complained about you know i can't relate
to them at all
i feel like americans are very just uh
you know out there in a good way most of
the time i really appreciate how
open americans are sometimes you just
wish they weren't though
um but i mean that's with anyone right
yeah i'm sure people wish that i would
shut the [ __ ] up for ten minutes
yeah but um man i mean i i feel like the
reason we love complaining about
americans is because
we hang out with a lot of americans yeah
we're right i mean
i'm dating americans this is the thing
as well where people are like man you
know nothing about american culture i'm
like man you really don't realize how
how outside america works do you yeah
literally all we get is your [ __ ]
leftovers that's like
your leftover movies your leftover tv
yeah
unfortunately i do know how it works
it's until you see yourself in the third
person that you realize
wow yeah we're weird like like out of
all these
hearing all of them again i'm just like
wearing shoes on bed yeah i'd say
wearing shoes on beard because like
um i think like most of these are just
like you know some of them
annoying some of them are offensive
whatever to me i think this one offended
my entire generation
like my [ __ ] my [ __ ] ancestors are
like turning in their [ __ ] graves
right now hearing this opinion
every asians pulling their hairs out
right now
yeah it's true yeah honestly yeah yeah
we kind of grouped i remember i remember
like we grouped uh
like the entire western world and like
the europeans are like no this ain't our
mans
you know i don't do that in the uk
there's only some households in the uk
do that and that's how you know they're
the weird kid yeah
yeah um i i am curious because i feel
like most people voting on this are
going to be american
yeah right yeah i'm gonna
i never thought about that i'm gonna
enjoy to see what the americans yourself
chose is the best american let's find
out
all right all right as the one who
apparently complains about america
yeah i'm very honest go on to read out
this award connor
oh this might surprise you okay well
which one do you think it is it's
i'll give you a clue it's not it's not
the first one really yeah it's not the
first one which one do you think it is
americans are a different species of
human put the nail on the head
a different species wow
what's the percentage can we get the
breakdown i was not expecting that
forty one point nine percent fourteen
one point nine percent of the votes
what's the second one
wearing shoes on your bed good good good
good that should have won
well that's the thing is that we think
that's just absolutely
vital to every american voting on it
they're just like a lot of them don't
think of it as a big deal yeah
i mean fair enough you know fair enough
hopefully we have opened your eyes just
a little bit
honestly that's more opie for them they
can never take their shoes off
i guess but everyone around them is
going to be grossed out yeah i'm pretty
sure like humanity regresses every time
someone doesn't take their shoes off
when they get on the bench i remember i
had to call rustage out like this but
yeah
rustage when he came to my house in
japan did that he you know because in
japan you have the what's the gatekeeper
and i was like yeah this is my house and
i'm sure i'm like this is the because
the bathroom's right next to the phone
yeah all right
oh cool starts walking in with the shoes
on dirtier
into my i'm like
i'm ashamed of you i thought you're
better than that i like scrubbing the
floor
come on come on you're not even american
i was like you're not american rustic
what's your excuse
i said yes don't you like to change for
us it's not too late
to seek help you can change your others
i i can change
sorry i i know you said i forgive you
yeah now you know for next time